♪ ♪
>> Tammy: AND NOW AS THE
BIDEN-HARRIS SELF-INFLICTED
BORDER CATASTROPHE WORSENED BY
THE HOUR, THE DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR ALLIES IN THE MEDIA ARE ON
FULL ON DAMAGE CONTROL.
JUST LISTEN TO MSDNC'S JOY REID
SAY THE CRISIS DOESN'T EXIST.
SPEAK OF THE ROAMING GNOME IS
BACK AT IT AGAIN.
IT WOULD APPEAR AS THE INAUGURAL
ABSOLUTE WORST IS JEALOUS ALL
THE ATTENTION THE RECORD HOLDERS
ARE GETTING, SO SHE IS SENDING
SOUTH DAKOTA'S TROOPS ROLLING.
DEPLOYING THEM TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER OF TEXAS, JOINING
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS AND THE
GOVERNORS OF IOWA AND NEBRASKA
IN SENDING HELP TO THE BORDER.
50 NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS ARE
BEING DEPLOYED IN RESPONSE TO
GREG ABBOTT'S PLEA FOR MORE
BORDER SECURITY FOR A
NONEXISTENT CRISIS.
>> Tammy: NONEXISTENT.
IT BORDER ENCOUNTERS ARE ON PACE
FOR A DECADE HIGH.
CARTELS ARE EMBOLDENED.
HUMAN SMUGGLERS ARE OPERATING IN
PLAIN SIGHT, DRUGS ARE POURING
INTO OUR COUNTRY AND AUTHORITIES
ARE COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED.
REMEMBER, THERE IS NOTHING
COMPASSIONATE ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND NOTHING
COMPASSIONATE ABOUT
INCENTIVIZING THIS TREACHEROUS
JOURNEY.
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA TO THE U.S.
BORDER, IT IS INHUMANE FOR THE
MIGRANTS AND A SLAP IN THE FACE
FOR ALL OF US HERE AT HOME.
RECKLESS IMMIGRATION POLICY,
TRUSTED THAT OUR LEADERS WILL
FAITHFULLY EXECUTE THE LAWS AND
FAITHFULLY KEEP US SAFE AND
SECURE.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING AT THE BOARD
IS A FULL-FLEDGED PUBLIC SAFETY
RISK.
JUST LISTEN TO ONE MOM IN
DEL RIO, TEXAS, SAY SHE'S EVEN
SCARED TO HAVE HER KIDS PLAY
OUTSIDE.
>> I'M CONSTANTLY CONCERNED
RIGHT NOW WITH MY FAMILY'S
SAFETY AND ESPECIALLY THAT OF
OUR THREE DAUGHTERS.
>> WHEN PEOPLE SAY THAT IS
BECAUSE YOU LIVE ON THE BORDER,
HAS ALWAYS BEEN LIKE THIS
CUSTOMER COULD BE ALWAYS BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT YOUR FAMILY'S
SAFETY?
>> I THINK OUR SITUATION IS
UNIQUE BECAUSE WE USED TO LIVE
ON A VERY LARGE RANCH WEST OF
DEL RIO BUT WE MOVED TO DEL RIO
SEEKING THE NICE, QUIET YARD FOR
OUR GIRLS TO GROW UP AND PLAY AN
END WITHIN THE LAST SIX MONTHS
OR SO, ACTIVITIES HERE, IT WAS
PEACEFUL FOR A WHILE.
I WAS ACTUALLY ENJOYING HAVING
PEACE OF MIND AND ALLOWING OUR
KIDS TO PLAY OUTSIDE, BUT THEY
CAN'T DO THAT ANYMORE.
>> Tammy: WOW, THAT'S AWFUL.
DON'T FORGET, WHEN DONALD TRUMP
LEFT OFFICE THE BORDER WAS AS
SECURE AS IT EVER HAD BEEN BUT
THEN BIDEN SCRAPPED THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY.
HE ENDED CONSTRUCTION OF THE
BORDER WALL, HE REINSTITUTED
CATCH AND RELEASE AND IS OPEN
BORDERS RHETORIC SAID NO MORE
BORDER ENFORCEMENT.
HERE TO BREAK IT ALL DOWN,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR TOM HOMAN
ALONG WITH FOX & FRIENDS WEEKEND
COHOST AND AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE
UNION CHAIR MATT SCHLAPP.
LET ME START WITH YOU, TOM,
OBVIOUSLY IT'S HEARTBREAKING FOR
ALL OF US TO HAVE SEEN SUCH
SUCCESS FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP, TO
SEE OUR AGENCIES WORKING
SUCCESSFULLY TO SECURE PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND TO MAKE EVERYBODY'S
LIVES BETTER SOUTH OF THE BORDER
AND NORTH, AND NOW, WE JUST SEE
IT SET ON FIRE.
ESSENTIALLY IT SEEMS
DELIBERATELY SO.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON WHERE
THINGS STAND NOW?
>> THE BORDER IS IN COMPLETE
CHAOS.
I'VE BEEN ENFORCING IMMIGRATION
LAW FOR ALMOST 35 YEARS.
THIS IS THE WORST I'VE EVER SEEN
IT.
FOR FOLKS WHO SAY THERE'S NOT A
CRISIS I SUGGESTED SHE GO DOWN
TO THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY,
SOMETHING KAMALA HARRIS DIDN'T
DO, AND SPEND ONE HOUR WITH
BORDER CONTROL.
I'VE BEEN THERE FOUR TIMES.
WHEN I SPEND AN HOUR WITH BORDER
CONTROL I WATCH 197 ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS COME ACROSS OUR RIVER.
TWO WEEKS AGO I WAS IN ARIZONA
AND I MET WITH 100 BORDER
SHERIFFS.
PLUS MANY BORDER SHERIFFS AND
THEY WILL TELL YOU ABOUT THE
RISE AND FENNEL OVERDOSES
AND SEIZURES, TELL YOU ABOUT THE
RISE IN HIGH SPEED CAR
CHASES.
ONE BORDER SHERIFF ALONE TOLD ME
HE ALREADY FOUND 44 DEAD
MIGRANTS, WHY HE BECAME
PRESIDENT.
44 DEAD MIGRANTS AND ONE COUNT.
PLUS WITH THE LADY SAYS IS AN
INSULT TO THE MEN AND WOMEN ON
THE BORDER WHO ARE DEALING WITH
THIS CRISIS EVERY DAY.
I SUGGEST YOU -- BECAUSE SHE IS
DEAD WRONG ON THIS ISSUE.
WE HAVE A CRISIS OF IMMENSE
PROPORTIONS THAT I HAVE NEVER
SEEN IN MY CAREER.
>> Tammy: IT'S A GREAT POINT,
SIR.
RACHEL, THIS IS NOT JUST
THEORETICAL, RIGHT?
WE KNOW THERE'S TECHNICAL ISSUES
GOING ON AT THE BORDER BUT YOU
HEARD THAT MOM.
YOUR MOM, PEOPLE WATCHING THIS
ARE PARENTS, YOU HAVE PEOPLE YOU
LOVE, THIS IS ABOUT AN EVENT
THAT DIRECTLY IMPACTS THE SAFETY
AND SECURITY OF AMERICAN
FAMILIES.
THIS IS A REAL LIFE.
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING WITH THAT
MOM UNABLE TO FEEL SAFE LETTING
HER CHILDREN EVEN OUT OF THE
HOUSE?
>> THEY ACTUALLY CAUGHT AN
IMMIGRANT COMING UP HER DRIVEWAY
WHO ACTUALLY HAD A CRIMINAL
PAST.
THIS IS A REAL THING, SHE'S
PETRIFIED AND SAYS THE BORDER
PATROL IS TIED UP WITH
PROCESSING PEOPLE AND SHE WAS
LUCKY THAT SOMEONE IN LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAUGHT THIS MAN
AND TOOK HIM AWAY BUT REMEMBER,
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE GOING
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
BOB GOOD, A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
VIRGINIA WENT DOWN WITH THE
REPUBLICAN SENATE COMMITTEE TO
LOOK AT THE BORDER.
NOT ONLY DID THEY SEE THAT THE
BORDER WAS COMPLETELY OUT OF
CONTROL AS TOM HOMAN HAS SAID
BUT THEN HE WENT TO THE AIRPORT
TO GO HOME AND FOUND ALL THESE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN THE
AIRPORT, WITH MANILA FOLDERS AND
IN THESE MANILA FOLDERS THEY HAD
WHERE THEY ARE GOING, HOW TO
NAVIGATE THE AIRPORTS AND ALSO,
THEY HAD WHAT THEY CALL NOTICE
TO APPEAR PAPERWORK AND THAT
PAPERWORK SAID TO BE DETERMINED,
SO THEY ARE NOT EVER GOING TO GO
TO COURT, THEY ARE BEING
SPREAD OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
AND THE REASON JOY REID CAN SAY
THAT IS BECAUSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS IN BEING
HONEST ABOUT THIS.
I HAD SO MUCH MORE RESPECT FOR
THEM IF THEY TELL THE TRUTH.
SAYING WE OPENED UP THE BORDER,
WE WANT ALL THESE PEOPLE END, WE
ARE SENDING THEM TO AIRPORTS AND
PUTTING THEM ON BUSES AND
SENDING THEM ACROSS THE COUNTRY
BUT THEY ARE DOING IT AND LYING
TO US.
>> Tammy: GREAT POINTS,
RACHEL, GREAT STUFF ON THE
WEEKENDS, FOX & FRIENDS IN THE
MORNING.
THEY ARE LYING ABOUT IT BECAUSE
THEY KNOW AMERICANS DON'T WANT
IT.
AND THEY OF COURSE HAVE NO
REGARD FOR US, THEY THINK WE ARE
JUST GOING TO BELIEVE IT AND
SWALLOW IT WHOLE BUT THE FACT IS
YOU HAVE A DYNAMIC WHERE THIS IS
ONCE AGAIN, FORGET ABOUT QUALITY
OF LIFE WHETHER IT IS IN CHICAGO
OR AT THE BORDER OR IN
LOS ANGELES AND DOING THIS
BECAUSE THEY THINK IT IS GOING
TO GET THEM POLITICAL POWER.
IS THAT GOING TO UNFOLD AND WILL
IT BE SUCCESSFUL?
>> LOOK AT WHERE SOCIALISM IS
BEING ENFORCED IN OUR MAJOR
CITIES.
PEOPLE ARE FLEEING THEIR CITIES
AND MOVING TO STATES LIKE TEXAS
AND AT ONE OF THE PEOPLE DOING
WHO ARE CLOSEST TO THE BORDER?
WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THEY ARE ACTUALLY ELECTING
REPUBLICANS TO MAKE ORAL SEATS
IN HISTORIC WINS.
THEY ARE CHANGING SEATS ON
SCHOOL BOARDS BECAUSE THE
SOCIETAL UNREST ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS ILLEGAL CROSSING IS
SOMETHING THAT THE PEOPLE IN
TEXAS REALIZE, IF YOU LIVE ON A
BORDER YOU REALIZE WHAT THE
PROBLEMS ARE.
THE SECOND THING IS IT IS ABOUT
POLITICAL POWER, TAMMY.
HR WANTED ALL THESE LEGAL
REFORMS TAKE AWAY ALL THE VOTING
SECURITY.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A MILLION
NEW PEOPLE RUNNING AROUND THIS
COUNTRY THAT WILL HAVE NO
SECURITY ON VOTING.
THE MODERN DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
ALL ABOUT NOT FOLLOWING THE
RULES AND I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NEXT NOVEMBER ARE GOING
TO SEND THEM QUITE A MESSAGE.
>> Tammy: WE HAVE TO BECAUSE
WHILE YOU CAN HAVE POCKETS,
RACHEL, BACK TO YOU QUICKLY
HERE, WHEN YOU HAVE POCKETS OF
CITIES AND AREAS, WHETHER THEY
ARE BLUE ARE NOT WHERE THERE IS
SUCH CHAOS AND SUCH A LACK OF
"LAW & ORDER," THAT IS GOING TO
BREED EVEN MORE VIOLENCE.
EVERY AMERICAN MATTERS, ERASE
CITY MATTERS COME, WE DON'T CARE
WHAT
COLOR THOSE CITIES ARE, WE CAN'T
HAVE A DIVIDED NATION AND YET
THAT IS ALSO WHAT SEEMS TO BE HU
HAVE A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
QUALITY OF LIFE.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE DECISIONS
AMERICANS ARE MAKING AND WHAT
CITIES WE ARE FIGHTING FOR, WHAT
WOULD YOU TELL THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN, WAITING UNTIL THE MID
TERMS WHAT IS IT WE NEED TO DO
TO KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY SAFE?
>> WE NEED TO KEEP TALKING ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE THE LIES ARE SO
BAD.
KAMALA HARRIS IS CLAIMING THAT
SHE'S ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES
BUT THESE POLICIES ARE ACTUALLY
EMPOWERING, ENRICHING THE
CARTEL, WHICH IS GOING TO
FURTHER DESTABILIZE SUPPOSEDLY
THE ROOT CAUSES IN THE
COUNTRIES.
THIS IS ACTUALLY SO BAD AND IS
GOING TO GET WORSE AS MEXICO AND
CENTRAL AMERICA ARE HAVING
INCREASED VIOLENCE THERE.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE THAT POURING
ACROSS OUR BORDER, SEE MORE
PEOPLE TRYING TO FLEE AND WE
JUST HAVE TO STAND UP.
I THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT,
WE CAN'T WAIT UNTIL THE
MIDTERMS.
THIS THING IS GETTING OUT OF
CONTROL.
THERE'S A MILLION PEOPLE WHO
WILL BE HERE BEFORE THE END OF
THE YEAR AND WE DON'T KNOW WHO
THEY ARE.
>> Tammy: GREAT POINT.
TOM, IN THE MINUTE WE HAVE LEFT
HERE OR SO, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE, WE
SEE FAMILIES GOING TO THE SCHOOL
BOARD MEETINGS, WE SEE FAMILIES
GOING TO THE POLICE DEPARTMENT,
WE HAD A GREAT DECISION TO
MINNEAPOLIS ABOUT, THAT THEY
HAVE TO HIRE MORE POLICE
OFFICERS, BEYOND THE LARGER
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE DYNAMIC,
WHAT WOULD YOU WITH YOUR
EXPERIENCE TELL LOCAL FAMILIES
GETTING INVOLVED IN THEIR
COMMUNITY?
WHAT SHOULD THEY STEP UP TO DO
FOR US, YOU THINK?
>> THEY NEED TO START CALLING
THEIR CONGRESSMEN AND SENATORS,
THE RESPONSES THEY WORK FOR
THEM, NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
I WANT TO EXPAND RESUME RACHEL
JUST SAID.
KAMALA HARRIS TALKING ABOUT ROOT
CAUSES.
ALL KAMALA HARRIS HAS TO DO IS
WALK DOWN THE HALL TO THE
OVAL OFFICE AND SHE WILL FIND
THE ROOT CAUSES.
ANOTHER THING, RACHEL IS SPOT ON
AT THE AIRPORT.
I WAS AT THE AIRPORT DOWN AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER WITH THE
PRESIDENT TWO DAYS AGO.
AS A HUNDREDS OF FAMILY UNITS
COUNTING ON THOSE AIRPLANES AND
NOT ONLY THAT, THOSE TICKETS ARE
PAID BY THE U.S. TAXPAYER, YOU
GET A BRAND-NEW iPHONE
COMPLEMENTS OF THE TAXPAYER.
THIS IS MUCH WORSE THAN PEOPLE
REALIZE IT IS.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE A
GOOD TRIP DOWN THERE, HE GOT HIS
SHOES DIRTY ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, AND HE ACTUALLY TALKED
ABOUT SOLUTIONS TO FIX THE
BORDER, UNLIKE ANYBODY IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tammy: THANK YOU, TOM.
NOT ONLY PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE
REMAINS INSPIRATIONAL BUT SO CAN
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR OWN CITIES.
MAY BE NEVER THOUGHT YOU WOULD
HAVE TO TALK TO THE POLICE
COMMISSIONER OR THE MAYOR.
THAT IS YOUR RIGHT, YOU SHOULD
DO IT AND YOU STEPPING UP, SO
MANY PARENTS BECOMING
INSPIRATIONS BECAUSE OF VIRAL
VIDEOS BUT IT DOESN'T EVEN NEED
TO BE A VIDEO.
IT CAN BE ABOUT YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND YOUR COMMUNITY
SO THERE IS A GREA